Quand je commence des conférences comme celle-ci,
J'ai l'habitude de faire tout un speech au sujet du développement durable
parce que beaucoup de gens ne savent pas ce que c'est.
Ici tout le monde sait ce que c'est,
donc je vais juste faire un résumé en 30 secondes, ok?
Alors soyez indulgent avec moi. On va allez très vite, d'accord?
Remplissez les blancs.
Donc, vous savez, développement durable, petite planète.
Ok? Dessinez dans vos têtes une petite Terre, qui tourne autour du soleil.
Vous savez, il y a environ un million d'année,
une bande de singes est tombée des arbres,
ils sont devenus un peu intelligent, ont maîtrisé le feu,
ils ont inventé l'imprimerie,
ils ont aussi fait, vous savez, des valises avec des petites roulettes.
Et, entre autres, ils ont aussi construit la société dans laquelle nous vivons maintenant.
Malheureusement, alors que cette société est, sans aucun doute,
la plus prospère et dynamique que le monde ait jamais créé,
elle a des énormes, énormes défauts.
Un d'eux est que toutes les sociétés ont une empreinte écologique.
Un impact sur la planète qui est mesurable.
Combien de choses passent dans nos vies,
et combien de déchets nous laissons derrière.
Et dans notre société, en ce moment, nous
avons vraiment atteint un niveau dramatiquement non durable de ceci.
On utilise environ cinq planètes.
Si tout le monde sur la planète vivait comme nous vivons,
on aurait besoin d'environ cinq, six, sept,
il y a même des gens qui disent qu'il faudrait 10 planètes.
Il est assez évident que nous n'avons pas dix planètes.
De nouveau, donc, mentalisation, visualisation, 10 planètes, une planète,
10 planètes, une planète. Ok ?
Nous n'avons pas ça. Ça pose donc un problème.
Le deuxième problème, c'est que la planète que nous avons
est utilisée de manière terriblement injuste. N'est ce pas ?
Les Américains, comme moi-même, voyez,
en gros, nous sommes une bande de porcs goinfres et vautrés,
et nous mangeons toutes sortes de choses.
Et là, vous savez, si on regarde directement tout au sud,
les gens qui vivent dans la région Asie-Pacifique, ou encore en Afrique.
Ces gens n'ont simplement pas assez pour survivre.
Et cela produit toutes sortes de tensions,
toutes sortes de dynamiques qui sont profondément perturbantes.
Et il y a de plus en plus de gens en chemin vous savez?
Donc, voilà à quoi la planète ressemblera dans 20 ans.
Ca va être un endroit pas mal peuplé, au moins 8 milliards de personnes.
Et, pour rendre les choses encore plus compliquées, c'est une très jeune planète.
Un tiers des habitants de la planète sont des enfants.
Et ces enfants là grandissent d'une manière complètement différente
de celle de leurs parents, peu importe où ils vivent.
Ils ont été exposés à notre idée de la société, à notre prospérité,
Et ils ne veulent probablement pas vivre exactement comme nous.
Ils ne veulent pas être Américains, ou Anglais,
ou Allemands, ou Sud-Africains,
mais ils veulent leur propre version
d'une vie plus prospère, plus dynamique,
et plus, comment dire, agréable.
Et toutes ces choses se combinent pour créer
un énorme volume de tension sur la planète.
Et si on ne trouve pas un moyen de gérer ces tensions,
on va se retrouver de plus en plus rapidement
à affronter des situations qui sont tout simplement impensables.
Tout le monde dans cette pièce a déjà entendu les pires scénarios catastrophes.
Je n'ai pas besoin de rentrer là-dedans.
Mais je poserai la question, quelle est l'alternative?
Et je dirais que, au moment présent, l'alternative est inimaginable.
Alors, donc d'un coté on a l'impensable,
et de l'autre coté on a l'inimaginable.
Nous ne savons pas encore comment construire une société
qui vit en accord avec son environnement,
qui peut être partagée avec tout les habitants de la planète,
qui encourage la stabilité, la démocratie et les droits de l'homme,
et qu'il est possible d'atteindre dans le laps de temps nécessaire
pour réussir à passer au travers des challenges auxquels nous faisons face.
Nous ne savons pas encore comment faire ça.
Alors, qu'est ce que Worldchanging?
Et bien, vous pouvez voir Worlchanging
comme étant une sorte de service de nouvelles pour un futur inimaginable.
Donc ce que nous faisons ici, c'est essayer de trouver
des exemples d'outils, de modèles et des idées,
qui, s'ils sont largement adoptés, changeraient la donne. Ok ?
Souvent, quand je fais des conférences comme celle-ci, je parle de choses
dont je suis sûr que tout le monde dans la salle a déjà entendu parler,
certes, mais pas la plupart des gens.
Alors je me suis dit qu'aujourd'hui je ferai quelque chose d'un peu différent,
et que j'allais parler de ce que l'on recherche, plutôt que, comment dire,
plutôt que donner des exemples qui ont déjà fait leurs preuves.
Je vais parles des choses qu' on essaye de mettre en avant.
Vous donner un petit aperçu de notre carnet éditorial.
Et étant donné que je n'ai que 13 minutes pour faire ça, ça va aller assez vite.
Alors, bon, essayez de me suivre. D'accord ?
Donc, tout d'abord, qu'est ce que nous recherchons ? Des Villes Vertes.
Un des plus grand défis qui nous attend dans les pays développés
pour changer notre impact sur la planète
est de changer notre façon de vivre dans les villes.
Nous sommes déjà une planète urbanisée,
et c'est particulièrement vrai pour les pays développés.
Et les gens qui vivent dans les villes des pays développés,
on tendance à vivre assez aisément, et donc à aussi utiliser tout un tas de trucs.
Si nous arrivons à changer cette dynamique,
avant tout en créant des villes plus denses et plus vivables...
Ici, par exemple, c'est Vancouver, et si vous n'y êtes jamais allé,
vous devriez vraiment aller y faire un tour. C'est une ville fabuleuse.
Et ils développent une densité, une nouvelle densité,
mieux que probablement n'importe qui sur la planète en ce moment.
Ils sont en train d'apprendre aux Nord-Américains à moins utiliser leur voitures,
ce qui est plutôt une bonne chose.
donc, il y a la population. Il y a aussi la gestion de la croissance.
On laisse de côté ce qui est naturel être naturel.
C'est dans Portland. C'est un développement concret.
Ces terres resteront des pâturages permanents.
Ils ont fixé une frontière autour de la ville.
La nature, la ville. On n'y touche plus.
Un fois que vous faites des choses comme ça, vous pouvez commencer à faire toute sorte d'investissements.
Vous pouvez faire des trucs comme, par exemple,
des systèmes de transports qui fonctionnent
de manière efficace et raisonnablement confortables. N'est-ce pas ?
On peut aussi commencer par changer ce que l'on construit.
Voici le Beddington Zero Energy Development à Londres,
qui est un des bâtiments les plus écologiques au monde. C'est un endroit merveilleux.
On est maintenant capable de construire des bâtiments qui génèrent leur propre électricité,
qui retraitent plus leurs eaux,
qui sont beaucoup plus confortables que des bâtiments classiques,
qui utilisent un éclairage entièrement naturel, et cetera, et qui reviennent moins cher dans la durée.
Les toits Verts. Bill McDonough en a parlé hier soir, alors je ne vais pas trop m'étendre la dessus.
Mais lorsque les gens vivent
à proximité les uns des autres,
une des choses que l'on peut faire --
tandis que les technologies de l'information se développent,
c'est commencer à avoir des endroits intelligents.
On peut commencer à savoir où sont les choses.
Et quand on sait où sont les choses, cela devient beaucoup plus facile de les partager.
Quand on partage, on finit par utiliser moins.
Les réseaux de covoiturages sont un excellent exemple,
qui commence à vraiment bien décoller aux U.S.,
et qui marchent déjà très bien dans beaucoup d'endroits en Europe.
Si vous ne prenez votre voiture, disons, qu'un jour par semaine,
est-ce que vous avez vraiment besoin d'en être le seul propriétaire ?
Une autre chose que les technologies de l'information nous permettent de faire,
c'est commencer à comprendre comment consommer moins,
en sachant, et en contrôlant, ce que l'on utilise réellement.
Alors, voici un câble dont la lumière augmente lorsque vous utilisez plus d'énergie,
je trouve que c'est un concept plutôt sympa,
Bien que je pense que cela devrait marcher dans l'autre sens,
qu'il s'éclaire plus quand vous consommez moins.
Mais vous savez, il y a peut-être bien une approche encore plus simple.
On pourrait ré-étiqueter les choses.
Cet interrupteur affiche d'un coté, inondation subite,
et de l'autre coté, off.
Nous pouvons aussi changer notre manière de construire.
Voici un bâtiment biomorphique.
Sa forme est inspirée de la vie elle-même.
Beaucoup de ces bâtiments sont incroyablement beaux,
et aussi beaucoup plus efficaces.
Voici un exemple de technologie bio-mimétique,
c'est une chose à laquelle on s'intéresse de plus en plus.
Dans ce cas, c'est une forme de coquillage
qui a été utilisée pour créer une nouvelle sorte de ventilateur, qui est beaucoup plus efficace.
Il y a beaucoup de choses comme cela qui se passe, c'est vraiment remarquable.
Je vous encourage à aller jeter un oeil à Worldchanging, si cela vous intéresse.
On commence à couvrir ceci de plus en plus.
Il y a aussi le design néo-biologique,
dans lequel on utilise de plus en plus la vie elle-même
et où son processus devient partie intégrante de notre industrie.
Ici par exemple, ce sont des algues qui génèrent de l'hydrogène.
Nous avons donc un modèle potentiel, le modèle émergent que l'on recherche
à savoir comment prendre les villes dans lesquels la plupart de nous vivent,
et les transformer en grandes Villes Vertes.
Mais malheureusement, la plupart des habitants de la planète ne vivent pas dans les villes dans lesquelles nous vivons.
Ils vivent dans les agglomérations émergentes des pays en développement.
Et il y a une statistique que j'aime beaucoup utiliser,
qui est que nous ajoutons une ville comme Seattle tous les quatre jours,
une ville de la taille de Seattle de plus sur la planète tous les quatre jours.
J'ai donné une conférence à ce sujet il y a deux mois,
et il y avait ce type, qui avait fait des travaux avec l' O.N.U, qui est venu me voir
et il était tout stressé, et il m'a dit, regarde,
tu as tout faux, c'est complètement faux.
C'est tous les sept jours.
Donc, bon, nous ajoutons une ville de la taille de Seattle tous les sept jours,
et la plupart de ces villes ressemblent plus à ça qu'aux villes dans lesquelles vous ou moi vivons.
La majorité de ces villes grossissent à une vitesse incroyable.
Elles n'ont pas d'infrastructures existantes,
il y a des tas de gens qui se battent pour survivre dans la pauvreté,
et il y a un tas de gens qui essayent de voir
comment faire les choses autrement, n'est-ce pas?
Alors, de quoi avons-nous besoin pour transformer les mégalopoles
des pays en voie de développement en Villes Vertes?
Et bien, en premier, nous avons besoin de faire un tri sélectif.
Et c'est une des choses qui sont recherchées partout.
L'idée derrière ceci est que
si vous êtes une personne, ou un pays, bloqué dans une situation
dans laquelle vous ne disposez pas des outils et de la technologie donc vous avez besoin,
vous n'avez aucune raison d'investir dans les technologies de dernières générations, n'est-ce pas?
Vou feriez mieux de vous tourner
vers une version moins chère ou applicable localement des dernières technologies.
Nous avons déjà l'habitude de constater ceci avec les téléphones portables.
Dans tous les pays en voie de développement, les gens utilisent directement des portables,
sans passer par toute l'étape de la ligne fixe.
Quand il y a des lignes fixes dans les villes des pays en voie de développement,
c'est généralement des systèmes assez pourris qui ne fonctionnent pas souvent,
et qui coûtent énormément d'argent. N'est ce pas?
Alors j'aime beaucoup cette photo.
Particulièrement le Ganesh en arrière plan qui parle sur un téléphone portable.
Ce qui se passe donc, c'est que les téléphones portables s'infiltrent de plus en plus dans toutes les sociétés.
On en a tous entendu parler ici cette semaine,
alors je ne vais pas m'étendre plus que ça là-dessus, mis à part dire
que ce qui est vrai pour les portables est aussi vrai pour toutes sortes de technologies.
La seconde chose, c'est que les outils de collaboration,
que ce soit les systèmes de collaboration ou les systèmes de propriété intellectuelle
doivent encourager la collaboration. Pas vrai?
Quand vous laissez la liberté aux gens de travailler ensemble librement et d'innover,
vous trouvez toutes sortes de solutions.
Et ces solutions sont accessibles de différentes manières
aux personnes qui n'ont pas de capitaux. N'est-ce pas?
Donc, oui, nous avons aussi des logiciels open source,
Creative Commons et d'autres sortes de solutions Copyleft.
Et ces choses-là mènent à des choses comme ça.
C'est un Telecentro à São Paulo.
C'est un programme plutôt remarquable
ils utilisent des logiciels gratuits et open source, des ordinateurs d'occasion bidouillés,
et des bâtiments abandonnés
qui, mis ensemble, ont donné plusieurs centres communautaires
où les gens peuvent aller, avoir accès à internet haute vitesse,
et acquérir des compétences en programmation informatique gratuitement.
250 000 personnes par an maintenant utilisent ceci à São Paulo.
Et ces 250 000 personnes font parties des plus pauvres de São Paulo.
J'aime particulièrement le petit pingouin Linux dans le fond.
Ce à quoi ceci mène, entre autres, c'est une sorte d'explosion culturelle du sud.
Et une des choses qui nous intéressent énormément à Worldchanging
c'est la manière dont le sud se ré-identifie lui-même,
et se re-catégorise d'une manière
qui a de moins en moins à voir avec la plupart de nous dans cette pièce.
Alors, bon, je ne dis pas que Bollywood n'est qu'une réponse à Hollywood. Ok?
Comme la scène musicale Brésilienne n'est pas une réponse aux maisons de disques.
C'est faire quelque chose de nouveau. Il y a des nouvelles choses qui se passent.
Il y a une interaction entre eux. Et on aboutit à des choses merveilleuses.
Comme, je ne sais pas si vous avez vu le film " La Cité de Dieu?"
Oui, c'est un film fabuleux si vous ne l'avez pas vu.
Et tout tourne autour de ce sujet, tourné d'une manière très indirecte et artistique.
Il y a d'autres exemples radicaux
où la capacité à utiliser des outils culturels se répand de plus en plus.
Ces gens viennent juste de recevoir la visite
d'un bibliobus Internet en Ouganda.
Et ce sont leurs premiers livres qu'ils agitent dans les airs,
ce qui est, je pense, une image plutôt chouette, vous ne trouvez pas?
Donc il y a aussi la possibilité pour les gens de se rassembler
et de s'engager en leur nom propre de manière politique et civique.
D'une façon jamais vue auparavant.
Et comme nous l'avons entendu hier soir, et aussi plus tôt cette semaine,
ce qui est absolument, fondamentalement vital pour avoir la possibilité de former de nouvelles solutions,
c'est que nous devons former de nouvelles réalités politiques.
Et pour ma part, je voudrais dire que nous devons former de nouvelles réalités politiques,
pas seulement dans des endroits comme l'Inde, l'Afghanistan, le Kenya, le Pakistan,
mais aussi ici, chez nous.
Un autre monde est possible.
Et c'est un peu la grande devise du mouvement anti-mondialisation, non?
On en abuse un peu.
On dit qu' un autre monde n'est pas juste une possibilité, un autre monde est là.
Que ce n'est pas comme si on devait en quelque sorte imaginer
qu'ici devrait être différent, ce qui est une vague possibilité,
mais nous devons commencer à agir un peu plus pour cette possibilité.
Nous devons commencer à faire des choses comme Lula, le Président du Brésil.
Combien de gens connaissaient Lula avant aujourd'hui?
Ok, eh bien, c'est bien plus que la moyenne, je peux vous le dire.
Donc Lula, il est plein de problèmes, plein de contradictions,
mais une des chose qu'il fait,
c'est qu'il met en avant une nouvelle manière d'engager des relations internationales
qui transforme complètement la balance dans les standards de communication nord-sud
en une toute nouvelle manière de collaboration globalisée.
J'aimerai que vous gardiez un œil sur ce gars.
Un autre exemple de cette sorte de superpuissance de l'alternative
c'est l'essor de ces jeux qui sont ce que l'on appelle des jeux sérieux.
Ça nous intéresse beaucoup. Ça se développe partout.
C'est une capture d'écran de "A Force More Powerful."
"A Force More Powerful" est un jeu qui,
lorsque vous y jouez, vous apprends comment engager
une insurrection non-violente et un changement de régime.
En voici un autre. C'est un jeu qui s'appelle "Food Force",
et c'est un jeu qui apprend aux enfants comment gérer un camp de réfugiés.
Toutes ces choses contribuent de manière très positive et dynamique
à une importante augmentation, particulièrement dans les pays en développement,
de l'intérêt et de la passion des peuples pour la démocratie.
Nous avons tellement peu d'informations sur les pays en développement,
que nous oublions souvent qu'il y a littéralement
des millions de personnes qui y luttent pour changer les choses
pour accéder à plus de liberté, de justice, de démocratie, et moins de corruption.
Et vous savez, on en entend pas assez parler.
Mais pourtant cela se passe partout,
et cela fait partie de ce qui rend le changement possible.
Maintenant, quand on ajoute toutes ces choses ensembles,
quand on ajoute les avancées sélectives et les nouveaux outils,
vous savez, les trucs de superpuissance alternative et cetera, qu'est ce que ça donne?
Eh bien très rapidement, vous avez un futur Vert pour le monde en développement.
Vous avez, par exemple, un mouvement écologique qui s'étend de par le monde.
Vous avez -- c'est un immeuble à Hyderabad, en Inde.
C'est l'immeuble le plus vert au monde.
Vous avez de solutions de bases, des solutions qui fonctionnent
pour les gens qui n'ont pas de capitaux ou qui ont des accès limités.
Vous avez des ingénieurs qui transportent pieds-nus des panneaux solaires dans les montagnes reculées.
Vous avez un accès à la médecine à distance.
Ce sont des infirmières indiennes qui apprennent à utiliser des PDA
pour accéder à des bases de données qui contiennent des informations
auxquelles elles ne peuvent pas accéder de chez elles.
Il y a des nouveaux outils pour les habitants des pays en développement.
Voici des lampes LED qui aident à peu près un milliard de personnes dans le monde,
pour qui la tombée de la nuit est synonyme d'obscurité,
à avoir de nouveaux moyens d' opérer.
Ce sont des réfrigitateurs qui ne requièrent pas d'électricité,
ce sont des pots avec une forme de pot.
Il y a aussi des solutions pour l'eau. L'eau est un des problèmes les plus urgents.
Ici c'est un systme de récupération d'eau de pluie qui n'est pas cher du tout
et qui est accessible aux habitants des pays en développement.
Là c'est un système pour distiller l'eau en utilisant la lumière du soleil.
Ici c'est un attrape-brouillard, qui, si vous habitez dans une région humide ou tropicale,
distillera de l'eau propre et potable depuis l'air.
Là c'est un moyen de transporter de l'eau.
J'aime vraiment ça, vous savez -- Je veux dire, c'est une telle corvée de porter de l'eau,
et un jour quelqu'un a eu l'idée, et bien, et si on la faisait rouler?
Je veux dire, c'est un super concept.
C'est une invention merveilleuse, LifeStraw.
En gros, vous pouvez aspirer n'importe quelle eau avec ça
et elle deviendra potable avant qu'elle atteigne vos lèvres.
Donc vous savez, des personnes en situation désespérée peuvent avoir ça.
Ça c'est une des choses que je préfère à Worldchanging.
C'est un tourniquet inventé par la compagnie Roundabout,
qui pompe l'eau pendant que les enfants jouent. Vous voyez?
Sérieusement -- cela mérite d'être salué, c'est vraiment bien.
Et la même chose est possible pour des gens qui sont plongés dans une crise absolue, n'est ce pas?
Nous nous attendons a ce qu'il y ait 200 millions de réfugiés d' ici à 2020
à cause des changements climatiques et de l'instabilité politique.
Comment pouvons-nous aider ces gens?
Eh bien, il y a pleins de nouveaux concepts humanitaires géniaux
qui sont développés de manière collaborative partout sur la planète.
Certains de ces concepts intègrent des modèles d'action,
comme des nouveaux modèles pour l'instruction, au milieu de camps de réfugiés.
Des nouveaux modèles pédagogiques pour les déplacés.
Et nous avons de nouveaux outils.
C'est une des choses que je préfère par-dessus tout.
Est-ce que quelqu'un sait ce que c'est?
Le public: Ça détecte les mines.
Exactement, c'est une fleur détectrice de mines.
Si vous habitez dans un de ces endroits
dans lesquels sont dispersées en gros un demi-milliard de mines introuvables,
vous pouvez balancer ces graines dans les champs.
Et lorsqu'elles grandiront, elles grandiront autour des mines,
leurs racines détecteront les produits chimiques à l'intérieur,
et il ne faudra pas marcher là ou les fleurs deviennent rouges.
Oui, donc des graines qui peuvent vous sauvez la vie. Voyez?
(Applaudissements)
J'aime aussi, parce qu'il me semble
que les exemples, les outils que nous utilisons pour changer le monde,
sont obligés d'être beaux intrinsèquement.
Vous savez, ce n'est pas assez pour survivre.
Nous devons faire quelque chose de mieux que ce que nous avons.
Et je pense que nous y arriverons.
Juste pour conclure, selon les mots immortels de H.G. Wells,
Je pense que le meilleur reste à venir.
Je pense, en fait, que "le passé n'est que le début du commencement.
Tout ce qui est ou a été
n'est que le crépuscule avant l'aube."
J'espère que cela s'avèrera être vrai.
Et les gens dans cette pièce m'ont donné une confiance plus grande que jamais.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)